what's popping variants it's me Mt and
welcome back to the heavy spoiler show I
am so freaking excited that Loki is back
in all of his chaotic time slipping
glory and that he didn't turn into
spaghetti but what was the deal with
that anyway like why was Loki even at
risk for turning into spaghetti in the
first place and why was Mobius at risk
for losing his skin also where the hell
is the TVA and how the hell does a
temporal Aura extractor even work let us
dive into all of these questions today
my nerd babies also drop a quick thumbs
up if you could it really helps with the
channel and it would mean a lot to me
personally all right so I want to start
this video off by talking about this
whole spaghetti business and why Mobius
is harrowing trip in his cracked space
soup from this episode could have
revealed exactly where the TVA is in
relation to the MCU from what I can tell
so far in this first episode of Loki
season 2 is that the entire TVA is
located inside of a black hole which is
something that I've been trying to say
for the longest time now on the internet
mostly because the Loki season 1 finale
revealed that to us right from the very
start right after the Marvel Studios
intro for that finale we see what
appears to be the energies of an entire
universe be condensed into a singular
point before an explosion of energy
pushes the camera backwards to reveal
two large black holes into frame then we
zoom into the black hole on the right of
the screen and all the energy within it
to find a whole another Universe living
inside of that black hole with that
black hole's inner world then being
condensed into a bunch of super skinny
glowing strings energy before we finally
get the reveal that all of those skinny
strings are actually timelines that make
up the multiversal ring around he who
remains his Citadel at the end of time
this Revelation that Kang was
manipulating the sacred timeline from
within one of the black holes at the End
of Time caused me to freak the out
when I first noticed this a few years
back because it all makes sense and is
very much tied to science if you're
familiar with some of my past Loki
videos from my former employer then
you'll already be familiar with an
Astron rical concept that I brought up
called the black hole era of the cosmos
and the reason why I brought this up in
the past was to explain to everyone
exactly what these two black holes in
the Loki finale are and how they relate
to the end of time and the sacred
timeline itself because you see the
black hole era of the universe is
basically the hypothesized period of the
cosmos that occurs after every star in
the universe burns out when all the
energies of everything that have ever
existed become swallowed and consumed by
a near infinite sea of black holes right
before the very end of the cosmos itself
and this period lasts for a very long
time apparently lasting about 10 Duo
deilan to one Google years I have never
heard of the word duo deilan in my
freaking lifetime Duo deilan D Duo
dillian D Duo dillian Murphy what the
is this these are numbers that I
cannot even begin to Fathom like the
entire universe won't have any stars or
planets or asteroids or anything at that
point just a bunch of black holes
sucking in the remnant of every single
thing that has ever existed everywhere
which is kind of a bummer if you think
about it for too long but hey the good
news is you'll probably be long dead by
the time this happens so you know Silver
Linings and all that your molecules
won't feel a thing thanks to the Sweet
release of death thank you de what a pal
however What If You Were Somehow alive
during this black hole era and what if
you got sucked into one of those black
holes with the unbelievable levels of
gravity that these astronomical black
suckers naturally have what would happen
to your body if you were to suddenly
trip and fall into a black hole well I
hope you like Olive Garden because your
ass just got turned into spaghetti in a
process that scientists accurately and
hilariously call spaghettification and
it's a term that we can see written on
the ground in front of the door leading
outside of the TVA as part of a very
much needed warning for anyone not
wearing a protective suit with a crack
in it the immense gravitational pull of
a black hole that not even the speed of
light can escape from would literally
pull your body towards the the center of
that black hole until all the atoms that
used to make up your body were nothing
but an unbelievably long thin piece of
subatomic spaghetti this is precisely
why I believe they showed John Taylor's
1974 book black holes the end of the
universe in the credits and also why o
be says this line in the first episode
and then if it if it doesn't do that
well have you heard about how if you
fall into black hole you turn into
spaghetti no good the less you know
about that the better Obie says this
because the entire te TVA rests within a
massive black hole and if Loki were to
stay in this black hole space outside of
the TVA building for too long without a
suit his body would turn into atomically
thin spaghetti just like the multiversal
energies of the Sacred timeline were
turned into thin spaghetti strings of
energy we actually get a look at what
the MCU Multiverse black hole looks like
from outside that black hole very
briefly in Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness after strange in
America blue sco themselves away from a
crank Karen with a crown and no kids
they fly past a couple of Living
Tribunal heads right before flying right
in front of a giant black hole with a
bunch of spaghetti strings of energy
flying wildly about look at all that
spaghetti that right there is the
chaotically branching Multiverse that we
are now dealing with in Loki season 2
and it is only when strange flies into
this black hole that he actually starts
the process of hopping through the
timelines of the Multiverse like I made
a really great video about this a while
back on another channel that you can
check out here but speaking of this raw
time energy now let's talk about the
actual energy of the Sacred timeline
because this here is super important to
understanding exactly what a temporal
Aura is how it relates to the sacred
timeline and why falling into a black
hole may not exactly mean the end of the
universe thanks to the TVA now the
reason why Mobius his skin was at risk
for getting peeled in the first place
was because of the impossibly hot and
corrosive radiation emitting from the
raw energy of the timeline but what is
this mysterious rainbow energy well if
you've been following me for the last
few years then you probably already know
what I'm about to say as this is
basically the foundation for my theory
that connects all of the rainbow
energies of the MCU to the six Infinity
Stones and real world science a theory
that I call the Marvel trigger Theory
the Marvel trigger theory is
unfortunately too sciency and complex to
fully explain in this video right now
because your boy would have to start
explaining Cosmic Concepts like dark
energy which Nick Fury was studying at
the beginning of Avengers 1 at the dark
energy mission facility or dark matter
which is tied to chaos matter and The
Ether like Odin says in Thor 2 or green
MCU gravity which is what makes the Tim
Stone time travel of Doctor Strange one
possible and it's also why yon rag is
able to manipulate gravity with his
green magnetron gauntlets it's all
connected but in the interest of time
the main thing that you need to know for
this video is that every MCU Universe
has been painted with these six Infinity
energies that were released during every
universe's Big Bang every single corner
of the MCU 616 universe and and Beyond
is influenced by these rainbow energies
and every Universe would completely fall
apart without the laws that came with
them the actual physical six Infinity
Stones themselves are merely a byproduct
of the big Bang's rainbow explosion of
science energy onto the empty canvas of
the 616 Universe basically six souvenirs
from The Big Bang creation event itself
which is why anyone who can collect all
six stones can reshape reality as they
see fit with a snap with those snaps
effectively producing many Big Bangs of
energy and because the entirety of
everything in the Marvel Multiverse is
made out of infinity energy this is
exactly why people who get pruned look
like rainbows of energy as their bodies
disintegrate because human beings have a
ton of infinity energy living inside of
them not just because the universe is
all rainbow Infinity energy but also
because of the amount of infinity energy
the people of planet Earth have been
exposed to primarily due to the multiple
infinity stone snaps that have happened
since Avengers Infinity War like this is
prec precisely what I believe temporal
Aura is in Loki and why the temporal
Aura scan of Loki's body in season 1
looks the way it does because that is
what Loki's Infinity energies look like
from the inside and the best example
that we get of this in the MCU movies
themselves surprisingly comes in the
movie shuni specifically during the
moment when wwu is having his rainbow
ass Soul sucked out by the dweller in
darkness in order to gain more power
like that moment is when we can see the
infinity energy that exists in every
human exposed out of wenwu and while the
TVA calls this temporal Aura human
beings refer to these inner energies
within as their soul basically their
inner Chi this isqi energy Soul energy
Infinity energy so basically Mobius had
to use that temporal Ora extractor
directly on the sacred timeline itself
because the sacred timeline contains the
energies of everyone who ever lived in
the Multiverse rainbow energy so goddamn
hot and Powerful that it can melt the
skin right off of Mobius his body his
mustache would be no more and that would
be a crime now this all being said
knowing that the TVA is inside of a
black hole all of these rainbow Infinity
energies that the TVA manage as the
sacred timeline have to come from
somewhere right well much like we would
turn into spaghetti if we were to fall
into a black hole this is exactly why
the sacred timeline is a bunch of
spaghetti noodles itself that we saw
getting spaghettified during that
sequence in the season 1 finale I
believe that whatever primordial
universe or Multiverse that existed
before the formation of this black hole
that the TVA lives in had part of the
energies of everything that ever existed
in that prequel Universe eaten and
turned into spaghetti by he who remains
as black hole this is all just repurpose
energy from outside the black hole then
he who remains shaped those noodles into
a sacred timeline pasta with the help of
his time variance Authority and his
handy dandy time Loom essentially
creating a pocket Multiverse inside of
this black hole like this is also why
time us used to work differently in the
TVA in season 1 the laws of time go
straight out the window inside of a
black hole after all due to the crazy
amount of gravity that the black hole
produces and since our perception of
time is forever linked to the concept of
gravity in science time was never really
a factor for TVA agents like Mobius or
B15 until something mysteriously weird
happened during the Loki finale that
seems to have changed all that now
remember that weird moment in the Loki
finale when he remains just stopped
talking because he felt something in the
air shift before picking up an object
and then watching it fall down I
strongly believe that this was he who
remains detecting his black holes inner
shift in gravity and then immediately
testing how this new change in gravity
would function by watching how his desk
ornament fell that very moment of Kang
letting the sacred timeline cross what
he calls the threshold is when I believe
time traval might have become possible
within the TVA and the black hole itself
this all being said I honestly believe
he who remains was doing his thing
inside of the Citadel at the End of Time
long after the TVA came and went and
built the perfect sacred timeline for
him with their time Loom with Miss
minutes being the only TVA agent left to
manage the sacred timeline that all of
those human workers built I have a
feeling that the reason why the writers
have included time slipping as a central
part of this story was to show the
complete history of the TVA from
inception to its death and reveal how
the TVA and the Citadel existed on the
same Rock in the center of this massive
black hole a rock that we see has a
massive hole in the middle for a
mysterious reason in the Loki finale
there's a good chance here that this
hole is where the TVA actually used to
be before he who remains got rid of it
in the far future of the TVA after they
completed their eons of tireless pruning
for him with the very top floor of the
TVA being the very Citadel itself but
only time will tell but if there is one
thing that I have the utmost confidence
in is that the entire TVA is INS side of
this black hole on the right of the
screen from the Loki finale and that
this black hole on the left is likely
home to a completely different
Multiverse entirely but which specific
Multiverse that is has yet to be seen I
wouldn't be surprised if this is where
the Council of kangs were chilling at
because they themselves seem to be
managing a completely different
Multiverse because remember how Miguel
from across the spider-verse calls the
entire Marvel Cosmos the arachno
humanoid poly Multiverse
spiderverse huh that's stupid
it's called the arachno humanoid poly
Multiverse Miguel using the term poly
basically confirmed the existence of
more than one Multiverse in the Marvel
Cinematic Cosmos which makes perfect
sense considering that the future black
hole era of the cosmos will for sure
have way more than two black holes he
who remains himself shows us at least
three multiversal black holes during his
presentation of the multiversal war to
Loki and Sylvie so God knows how many
multiverses actually exist in the
growing Marvel Cosmos so this all being
said said expect black holes in
gravitational science to play a big role
in Loki season 2 especially since he who
remains his window was literally modeled
after a black hole itself with six
circles swirling around the center to
represent the six Infinity energies of
the universe being manipulated inside a
piece of creative genius by the set
designers to foreshadow the black hole
shenan ganner to come in season 2 God I
love this show so freaking much it's
glorious I need more of this show in my
eyeballs right now but anyways thank you
guys so so much for watching this video
you can follow Me @ mastertainment on
Twitter or Instagram or wherever I am on
the internet but most importantly you
can follow heavy spoilers here on
YouTube and make sure you hit that Bell
so that you can get notifications every
time we upload a video and also do not
forget to keep it locked on my boy
Paul's breakdowns for every episode of
Loki my dude is going in my dude is
looking at all the details that you
might have missed so please subscribe
today so you don't miss all that Paul's
the man but again thank you guys so much
for watching this video you guys are
awesome and I'll see you guys later for
more Loki
t